after aegon and his dragons burned our
last king heron the black and broke our
armies the defeated ironborn chose my
ancestor vekon greyjoy as lord of the
iron islands not king
the stories claimed that the old way
died with her and the black and his sons
at harrenhal our ships and axes were no
match for aegon's dragons so our
ancestors bent their steel into
fishhooks and our kingdom into villages
and started telling the red tails around
the fire of how we used to be strong and
how one day would be so again
generations later a young boy listened
to them dalton greyjoy
the wild young heir to pike
was rowing at five and reaving a tin in
the basilisk isles with his uncle by 14
dalton had sailed as far as old geese
fought in a dozen battles
and claimed four soft wives
in his fifteenth year he avenged his
uncle's death in battle
but he took a dozen wounds and emerged
from the fight drenched head to heel and
blood
from that day forth
men called him the red kraken
during the dance of dragons
the red kraken picked the side that was
fighting the lannisters
and fell upon the westerlands while the
lannisters were up at war casterly rock
itself proved too strong
once the lady of the castle barred its
gates
but the ironborn burned the lannister
fleet and sacked land his support
carrying off gold grain and hundreds of
women and girls including lord
lannister's favorite mistress and all
his bastards
the red kraken now ruled the sunset sea
as his forebears had and his longships
again brought the old way to the coast
of westeros but then the war ended and
the mainland armies came home
the iron throne commanded the red kraken
to stop reeving and when he didn't
a mistress opened his throat as he slept
while his son squabbled
the lannisters send their soldiers to
the iron islands
thousands of men women and children were
put to the sword
and scores of villages and hundreds of
longships were put to the torch
the glorious return to the old way had
lasted almost two years
it should not be hard to recruit lords
into a war against an enemy known as the
mad king we can even understand the
lords who chose to honor their oaths and
fight for him but the krakens of house
greyjoy set out robert's rebellion on
pike with their tentacles up their arse
my father quellen was old and sitting is
what old people do best
well
second best he would have sat out the
whole wall if not for my brother and me
we convinced him that nobody would fear
the walls of the sea if we curled up by
our fires while others feasted on the
spoils of the mad king
so the old man cranked into his rusty
armor and set sail for the reach
only to be routed by terrell longboats
when my father sadly fell in battle
my older brother bailin beat a tactical
retreat to his own inheritance as the
new lord of the iron islands
i'd rather die in the reach than live on
the iron islands
the roses are brilliant to pluck
but my brother was getting old and felt
that longing to sit
and the sea stone chair was as good a
place as any
within a few years he realized that
sitting is only fun if everyone else has
to stand
he had the priest reforged no that's not
right
they picked up sticks on the beach
evolved them into a new ancient
driftwood crown
and declared balaam the king of the iron
islands
unfortunately for my brother the other
king and westeros robert baratheon was
famously bad at sharing and his father
by law and warden of the west tywin
lannister had a mighty fleet atlantis
port within striking distance of the
iron islands
yes you were very clever and how brave
burning our ships at anchor in the night
they would have burned the same in
daylight
vines the lazy beasts
you didn't rouse until long after i set
fire to a proud mane
i planned it all you know
my first torch took your father's
flagship
if it makes you feel better
we didn't lose it
out of respect
and time
i don't think i ever saw robert happier
than the day he heard about the greyjoy
rebellion
he'd been king for a handful of years
and many handfuls of other things
and it was clear to him and everyone
else how ill-suited he was to rule but
battle he could do
unfortunately by the time we raised our
army we seemed to be winning the war
balon's eldest son your nephew died
trying to storm seaguard and his men
were thrown back into the arms of their
drowned god
if we wanted battle we'd have to hurry
north before the ironborn put down their
own rebellion
and we would have if i've had my way
rebelling was a stupid idea
never stopped your people before
before bailin put those sticks on his
head i told him that if he wanted to
rule the iron islands all he had to do
was give king robert a tour of them why
waste our forces fighting a war we
couldn't win for a place our enemy
wouldn't want
with the iron fleet we could reef not
just westeros but the rich lands beyond
the sunset sea
but my brother was too attached to that
sea stone chair he commanded me to sail
the iron fleet against robert's navy
before we could ferry his army to pike
a navy commanded by robert's younger
brother stannis most known for sitting
in a besieged castle eating dogs and
horses
remind me how did you fare against a man
who'd never commanded ships in battle
nearly too well
stannis smashed your iron fleet at fair
isle
after i sailed it into a street where
our numbers and the size of our ships
would work against us
it took some doing to convince my men to
rush into such an obvious trap
stannis was not a
subtle man
you would rather claim treason than
defeat
victory would have only delayed it we
couldn't hold off robert's forces
forever
but we could waste enough ironborn that
we wouldn't even fill our own islands
after the war
i made sure the silence escaped
that was enough for me
that and watching your army smash my
brother's castle soon afterwards
why didn't you just abandon him after
fair isle why risk your precious life
fighting for him at pike
i wanted to kill the best knights in
westeros
you failed
so did you
i expected pursuit when i fled pike on
the silence
but i suppose you were too busy not
punishing my brother to not punish the
man who burned your father's fleet
where the north has its honor and the
south its chivalry the iron islands has
its strength
we call ourselves the ironborn and we
are warriors feared throughout the seven
kingdoms
or so we used to be
unlike their mainland cousins the first
men of the iron islands never bowed to
the old gods
theirs was the drowned god
who made the ironborn to reeve and sack
and write their names in salt steel and
song that his enemy the storm god could
not wash away
we raised our kings from our own ranks
and used beaten foes as thralls to work
our minds and farm our land
our assault wives if a woman was pretty
enough
such was the old way and while we
followed it we held sway wherever the
waves were heard
when aegon came demanding fealty king
harren the black ruled as far east as
the trident
other kings like the starks could kneel
but harren was ironborn and the ironborn
must be beaten
in harrenhal he had the mightiest castle
in westeros
and the army to defend it
but aegon did not intend a siege
he mounted his dragon and roasted haron
and all his sons in their tower and the
old way with them
because of aaron's defiance aegon pushed
the ironborn back to our islands and
gave the riverlands to the tullys
but he did allow the ironborn to choose
who would lead them
house greyjoy had always been one of the
greatest houses of the iron islands
we trace our descent from the age of
heroes and the legendary grey king
who took a mermaid to wife and made war
upon the storm god for a thousand years
blessed by the drowned god the grey king
fought and slew naga the great sea
dragon and took her fire for his own
this history made our ancestor vikon
greyjoy the natural choice to lead the
ironborn after aegon's conquest
for 300 years house greyjoy ruled the
ironborn
we styled ourselves lord of the iron
islands king of sultan rock
son of the sea wind lord reaper of pike
in truth we were thralls
our people still chanted what is dead
may never die
but the old way had died
until the targaryens followed their
dragons into the grave
and our lord father balon greyjoy rose
against the new king robert baratheon
dark wings dark words
i was only a boy when the raven came to
call my father lord eddard stark to
another war
balon greyjoy had raised the iron
islands in revolt and burned the
lannister fleet at anchor
king robert baratheon again needed his
old friend
my mother catelyn was not happy to lose
her lord husband to robert again
six years before he had left her to
avenge his father and brother against
the mad king
but now he had sons and daughters of his
own and unspoken
another son who wasn't hers from the
last time he went to war
my brother jon snow
but she knew that in marrying my father
she had married the north
we hold our honor and duty as dear as
our old gods
when the time came my father marched
south to restore peace and order to the
realm
my father always told me the iron
islands were a strange and dangerous
place
its people the ironborn keep neither the
old gods nor the seven and despise all
honest toil their ancestors ravaged the
western shores and putting it to the
torch and their songs still ring through
the halls of the ironborn
while everywhere else they whispered to
wayward children at bedtime perhaps lord
balon thought westeros had not healed
from the war against the mad king and
was as fragmented and suspicious as the
ancient kingdoms his forebears had
terrorized
robert's navy corrected him at fair isle
when they smashed the proud iron fleet
robert and my father corrected him at
pike his own castle when they pulled
down his towers and breached his walls
my father never liked to speak of his
battles but from other men i learned
what transpired
thoros of mia was first through the
breach with his flaming sword
not far behind him was jorah mormont of
bear island my father's bannerman who
earned the knight hoodie would later
shame and launch from every corner of
the seven kingdoms
all day through every passage in the
castle they fought side by side my
father with our ancestral sword ice and
king robert with his warhammer against a
horde of acts wielding ironborn
in the end
lord balon bent the knee
king robert generously allowed lord
balon to retain his tithe and castle
the price of peace was custom
the only son of balance to survive as
foolish rebellion would be taken as a
hostage against future treasons
my father even volunteered to foster the
boy himself
i suspect
to make theon greyjoy a different man
than his father who would bring honor
and duty to the iron islands when he
returned as heir
so my mother's silent fear came true and
my father returned with another child